all right let's get into audience emails
for the week you can email info
davidpackman.com sometimes tweets or
Facebook messages or YouTube comments
may be included
um let's just get right into it because
there's so many to get to today you know
one of the funny things that happens
every time we stream a trump rally is
people who have no idea about our
Channel or anything they'll just kind of
like come by because they're looking for
the rally and then they'll see oh here's
someone talking about it that's me and
then they'll realize I'm not saying
positive things and then they get really
mad and they will start emailing so as
you can see this one in particular
happened during a recent rally on a
Saturday and Landon wrote in and just
does an all caps we love Donald Trump
you are
and then that was the end of the email
apparently they accidentally sent it so
then they follow up and they say a bum
they meant you are a bum pack it up
loser and then a little bit later by the
end of the thing they they say I can't
wait until the Patriots cancel you and
you need to get a real job get a real
job commie
and uh this is pretty common
of course this is not a communist show
and this is a real job and and in fact I
think that lots of these folks have no
clue what is going on when it comes to
Independent Media but I always
appreciate them coming by and
contributing their you know increasing
the view count by one increasing the
comment count by a couple so thanks
Landon a Monty Roden also during a
recent Trump rally
and said you are a stoop SOB you think
dumbass Biden is good for this country
when we are paying five dollars a gallon
under his administration five dollars
for a loaf of bread eggs are twice as
much now than when Trump was President I
could on and on about the inflation
under Biden I also live by the Mexico
USA border and I've never seen so bad as
it is now crime has doubled under Biden
and on that subject I could go on and on
I Came Upon Your show by accident and
I'm glad I did because now I can use you
to show my liberal friends just how
stupid they are when Biden is not trying
to introduce dead people he's wrecking
our country with the support of idiots
like you
well Monty I'd appreciate you sending
some of those folks to my channel we're
trying to get to 2 million subscribers
on YouTube so uh yeah send them my way I
would very much very much appreciate
that Julia wrote in about my commentary
last week about
um uh leftism masculinity and the poll
that found that young women are moving
more to the left but young men are not
and Julia said I thought about your
segment today on the young women
becoming more leftist as opposed to
young men staying where they are I agree
with you that many men simply don't
admit to others that they're on the left
and the reason could be backlash from
the right-leaning friends and family
just look at these crazy right-wing nuts
calling you gay pejoratively without any
reason solely based on political opinion
keep doing what you're doing best of
luck to you and your family yeah I think
that Julia is more or less spot on and
it more or less also Echoes the comments
that I made last week you know there's
been this sort of cartoonish stereotype
of what
masculinity is supposed to be under the
Republican party and what's really funny
about it is that Trump
has espoused that idea and so have many
of his followers
despite Trump himself not
actually being that uh in fact being
very much the opposite in many ways and
that's because the facts don't really
matter it just it doesn't really make a
difference to them
um but that is the sort of picture that
they have designed and it's not a new
picture right I mean when we talk about
they want to go back to the to the 1950s
part of what we're talking about are
those
quite rigid views in fact on uh on
gender and femininity and masculinity so
I think I think Julie is definitely on
to something here's another message a
trump missing documents a while back
when this was breaking someone on Mt I
don't know what that is speculated about
them being in ivanka's casket
the documents being in ivanka's casket
now I think what the person means is
ivana's casket Ivana Trump recently died
it was all about the same time and she
noted that it took 10 strong men to
carry the casket which supposedly
contains her ashes she was mostly joking
but the more things move along the more
it seems plausible don't they have some
ground penetrating radar they could use
to check it out listen I have heard all
of these different hypotheses about
uh Ivana was buried where she was buried
I guess at or near some golf course for
a tax deduction
um there were documents in the casket
there are burned up documents and they I
have no idea it's really not super
interesting to me there are so many
other things going on it's speculative I
don't know that we would ever really
find out if something like that was
going on my thought is I don't want to
put too much of my time into that but I
know that there are many people who have
been speculating about the details of
Ivana Trump's casket I will leave it to
them
Luke wrote in and says thank you hey
David just want to say thanks for all of
your work on the show congratulations on
1.5 million subscribers I've been
listening to your show for about three
years now and much more engaged in
politics than I was before I started
listening I used to be sort of an
apolitical independent who thought both
left and right were equally bad ah yes
we call that enlightened centrism
uh uh okay
over the past few years I've started to
realize how the radical how radical the
right Wingers have become in the Trump
era and consider myself very
left-leaning now you certainly have had
a big influence on that change you also
have a talent for clearly communicating
ideas that is all too rare which I find
myself emulating to some degree
in my job as a teacher keep up the good
work you're making a difference here's
to 2 million subscribers you know it's
so rare that we just get like a nice
email in of that kind
that I love that and I Love featuring it
Johnny Road wrote in and says there are
multiple oh how many followers on
Twitter have you lost there are multiple
countless of reporting of users that are
reporting that they have lost tens of
thousands of followers have you lost
many or any I don't even follow these
people and never would writing an
article about it now yeah so when it the
first time that it was announced that
Elon Musk was buying Twitter
tons of uh right-wing accounts gained a
ton of followers and some left-wing
accounts lost some followers I lost some
it wasn't really clear why was it people
leaving the platform joining the
platform because of the news I guess
um then it looked like Elon Musk wasn't
going to buy Twitter now that again it's
looking like he might buy it
um there were I lost four followers on
the day of that announcement now I
gained followers every day like you go
you go back hundreds of days every day I
gain followers so losing any is weird I
don't really understand it maybe it's
that on the news of Elon buying Twitter
again a bunch of left Wingers said I'm
not going to be on a platform owned by
Elon Musk so they they quit they
canceled and deleted their account I
don't really know but it was very very
minimal at least on my end Edward wrote
in about current gas prices
and says David sir why is it that
Republicans no longer talk about gas
prices pretty obvious I just think it's
funny how Republicans only pin gas
prices on Biden when they're high to be
clear I'm in agreement with you
president doesn't control gas prices in
either direction I just find it funny
how Biden is only associated with high
gas prices in their mind love your show
Edward well Edward's wrong about one
thing
it is true that many of them are just
not talking about gas prices anymore
many are talking about them in line
Trump keeps saying they're so high and
they're going even higher and he'll use
numbers a little bit less now that gas
prices are down the other thing is over
the last few days they've actually
started to take back up and again these
very same people who have been totally
silent on it for weeks now months in
fact are now back to talking about the
gas prices it's the same Circle it's
worthless it's it's really not worth
much of our time they're going to do
their routine no matter what's going on
with gas prices uh it I say we just move
on and focus on more important things
a t Rodin and asks why
says Trump's most likely going to run
for president again
my question is why would someone enter a
race and expect to win when they know
the other side's cheating if he enters
the presidential race it is a total
admission he never believed the race was
stolen not quite
the logic here is good logic which is
if Democrats have it all rigged
why would any Republicans even bother to
run why would any Republicans even
bother to vote because Democrats are
just going to steal it the way they get
around this is they say if enough of us
vote it will overwhelm the voter fraud
and so we can still win even though
there will be some fraud that's how they
kind of close the illogical Loop of
logic that they've created they say yes
there's going to be fraud it's rigged
they're cheating but if we have a big
enough margin we'll end up winning by a
little bit after all of their cheating
is accounted for I I know it doesn't
make any sense it's completely wacky but
that's their argument that's what they
claim
info davidpackman.com get your questions
in comments requests for Corrections I'm
glad to entertain and even a little bit
of trolling not too much but a little
bit of trolling we have a great bonus
show for you today sign up at
joinpakman.com you'll get instant access
instant and then if you are not part of
that group we'll be back Monday with a
new show and a new bonus show